listen up scream queens fans the Red
Devil killer was finally revealed in
Tuesday's insane two-hour finale and
only et has the exclusive scoop straight
from the star leave right now if you do
not want to know the bloody Trish
Lea Michele I just discovered that
Hester is the killer she is the Red
Devil killer you might have noticed that
I'm the only Chanel left that's because
I got away with it I found it out
literally days before I started shooting
the episode we were in New York doing
I'm a press event for scream queens it
was me keke and Emma so I said how did
you guys get the script and Kiki's like
yeah did you read it
and I was like no I said who's the
killer and she was like it's you I was
like are you serious and then Ryan comes
up to me and he's like are you happy and
I was like oh I am happy but I'm am I
gonna die like what's gonna happen he's
like no you get away with that I have it
all worked out I was like okay I guess
it's good so I'm wearing my Red Devils
cape today just to emphasize that I'm
the killer you know there's a show on TV
that's all about how to get away with
murder how does it feel knowing that you
actually were able to I think that she
definitely was was in that that class
with those guys just figuring out how to
get away with it because she's really
skilled and more so the fact that she
was able to get away with not killing
anybody
she only kills one person but he's an
actual killer so um you know that she
was able to have this all done with her
hands pretty much clean I think is a
really good thing you rich dog holes are
going down
there is a season - would you be up for
it of course what do you mean I'm
already waiting I'm like patiently
waiting
obviously Ryan has shared with a few of
us what his ideas for next year are I
think that they're so you know exciting
and I'm down I think it'll be really
great to to see Hester you know in that
environment Ryan shared that next year
would be a whole new killer so to see
her really in the position of being you
know the the victim I think will be
really fun to play